You can't tell
from looking at me,
but I actually grew up
deep in the woods.
My childhood home was
an antiquated log cabin
surrounded by so much forest,
you couldn't even see
the distant road in the winter.
So I spent my free time
playing among the trees,
climbing their branches,
and seeing what treasures
I could discover
among their roots.
We relied on wood from those
trees to warm our house,
cook our meals,
and heat up water.
Some provided
food, others syrup,
and they all provided shade.
That childhood, while
certainly imperfect,
gave me a deep
appreciation for nature.
I was so grateful for
everything the trees provided
that I did the 21st century
equivalent of begging Gaia
to turn me into a dryad
and got a tattoo of
an oak tree on my arm.
But I was by no means
the first person
to pay my respects
to the majestic tree.
Humans around the world
have been doing that
for thousands of years
in ways that were
immortalized in our myths.
[light upbeat music]
Even without all of the vital,
practical things trees provide,
it's hard not to see them
as divine or magical.
Their sheer size
can seem to connect
the Earth to the heavens,
and their centuries
long lifespans
mean a single tree can
watch over a family
or community for
several generations,
long enough that its
origin fades into legend.
Even the deciduous trees that
shed their leaves every year
blossom again in the spring,
showing that they
weren't dead at all,
just taking a little nap before
it returned with its gifts.
It was easy for many
of our ancestors
to interpret
something so immortal
and abundant as the gift
or even embodiment of a god.
But I think the
reciprocal nature
of our relationship to trees
is the real reason they're
so common in folklore.
We rely on them,
but they also rely on us.
And beneath every story about
the wonders trees provide,
there's a sometimes
not so hidden message
about what will happen if
we don't take care of them.
In Thailand,
Buddhist folklore tells
of a tree called
the Nariphon or Makkaliphon
that grows fruit in the
shape of young women.
According to one of the
Jataka or a series of texts
that described the various
lives of the Buddha,
the trees were planted
in a sacred grove
by the god Indra
to protect, Maddi,
Buddha's wife in
a previous life.
In that life the Buddha was
known as Prince Vessantara,
the son of a woman who
was beloved by Indra.
Vessantara was so generous
that he was exiled
from his own kingdom
for giving a gift that
he shouldn't have.
While in exile, Vessantara
and Maddi traveled
through the legendary
Himavanta forest
full of dangerous creatures.
It's said that Indra shaped
the fruit like a young woman
to entice ill-intentioned
men who would be drawn
to the Nariphon for obvious
and disgusting reasons.
Thus, they would be
distracted from chasing Maddi.
If a man picked the
Nariphon's fruit
and took it to his bed, gross,
he would quickly
find himself sterile
and stripped of any
powers he might possess.
Women, however, were
immune to the fruit,
and instead could use it
as a fertility talisman if
they waited for the fruit
to fall naturally from the
tree after a week of growing.
The location of the
legendary Himavanta forest
and the grove of Nariphon
trees is unknown,
but you can still
find street vendors
in Thailand who claim to sell
these woman shaped dried
fruits to boost fertility.
Just a few years ago, a video
circulating on social media
showing what appeared to be
one of these Nariphon trees
got a lot of attention.
Though the videos were
never verified as real,
this shows that the myth
of woman-shaped fruit is alive
and well in Southeast Asia.
So for some cultures, trees
and their fruits were gifts
from the gods to us humans.
Other stories positioned trees
as the botanical embodiment
of a mystical figure.
For example, the dryads who
helped inspire my tattoo
were minor Greek goddesses
or nymphs who inhabited
and looked after
trees and woodlands.
Dryads served as the
spirits of trees,
and when they flourished,
their tree thrived.
When a dryad was sick or
injured, so was their tree.
Originally, the term
dryad only referred
to the spirits of oak trees,
which were considered
sacred to Zeus.
Ash trees were
guarded by Meliae,
certain mountain
trees by Oreiades,
and fruit trees by Meliades.
Laurels were inhabited
by the Daphnaie,
named for the
water nymph Daphne,
who was unlucky enough to catch
the god Apollo's attention.
After running from the
sun god's advances,
Daphne implored Gaia,
the Earth mother, for help.
She was transformed
into a laurel tree
and saved from Apollo's
relentless pursuit,
only for the laurels
she protected
to become sacred to
the god she fled.
Dryad eventually became the
general term for any tree nymph
due to the oak trees
prevalence in ancient Greece
and their connection to
the king of the gods.
As spirits of the forest,
dryads could make plants
grow or die as they pleased,
but mostly they acted as
stewards of their woods.
This idea that trees and
other elements of nature
each had their own living spirit
certainly wasn't
unique to the Greeks.
Animism was practiced
by many of Europe's
pre-Christian pagans,
like the Celts and Germanic
tribes who respected
or even worshiped the
spirits of inanimate things.
Those spirits weren't
necessarily
considered gods, however.
As far as we can tell,
the Celtic Tree of Life,
or Crann Bethadh,
was central to Celtic culture,
but it didn't represent
a specific important deity.
Instead, it represented
the balance of forces in nature.
The Celts saw a beauty
in the way that the trees roots
stretched deep below ground
while its branches stretched
high into the heavens,
demonstrating the connection
between different
realms of the cosmos.
To the Celts, the tree
of life was an oak tree,
likely because these were
the oldest tallest trees
in their sacred forests,
so tall that they would
often be struck by lightning,
which would be interpreted
as a sign of their
favor by the gods.
Plenty of other cultures
had their own tree of life
that represented the
balance of natural forces,
but some of them also
provided connections
between different worlds.
These are often called
world or cosmic trees.
We mentioned the baobab tree
in our episode on
Yoruba folklore.
This tree was said
to be the home
of the Orisha in
their heavenly realm
before Obatala created
land down here on Earth.
The baobab is often called
the African Tree of Life
because of the way it
looms over the desert,
providing shade and
hundreds of valuable uses
with its bark and sap.
Those trees can
live for 3000 years
and grow over 100 feet
tall and 50 feet wide.
Many origin myths for the baobab
involve it being
planted upside down.
In one story, the baobab tree
kept walking after
it was planted,
so God ripped it up and
replanted it upside down.
In another, the hyena
was assigned the job
of planting the baobab
tree, but found it so ugly
that he planted
its branches in the dirt.
Another cosmic tree
on the other side of the world
is the Ceiba, sacred to many
peoples throughout the tropics,
including the Maya
of Mesoamerica
and the Taino from
Puerto Rico and the Caribbean.
The Mayans called it Yaxche
and believed it was a world tree
that acted as the scaffolding
for their universe.
The Ceiba trees'
irregular bloom cycle
demonstrated the unbreakable
and traversable tether
between life and death.
So it's no surprise
that Yaxche's roots
and branches served as portals
to the Mayan afterlife.
Spirits could climb them to
reach their final destinations.
The Ceiba tree is such an
important cultural symbol
that when a 400 year old Ceiba
blossomed on Vieques island
after being ravaged by
Hurricanes Irma and Maria,
the islanders saw it as a sign
of hope and encouragement
that they would bounce
back from all the damage.
Perhaps the most well-known
world tree for mythology
is the Norse Yggdrasil.
This cosmic tree
was said to hold
all the nine worlds
of the Norse cosmos
in its roots and branches,
including Midgard and Asgard.
Some sources claim that
Yggdrasil is an ash tree,
but that's hotly debated.
Regardless of its exact species,
Yggdrasil's health is
vital to the health
of the Norse universe and
to their head god, Odin.
According to legend, Odin
sacrificed his own blood
and his eye to himself
by voluntarily hanging
from Yggdrasil for
nine days, as one does.
In doing so, he gained
knowledge and wisdom.
World trees serve
the paramount purpose
of balancing life forces and
supporting a stable universe.
But if you have more
selfish desires,
you'll want to look
for a wishing tree.
Throughout the world,
ancient and modern people
alike have made wishes on trees
by tying ribbons
to their branches,
hammering special
coins into their bark,
or tossing notes
into their canopies.
Hindu myths tell of
the Kalpavriksha,
a wish granting
tree that emerged
from the primordial waters
during a legendary battle
between the gods or devas
and demons or asuras.
After being poisoned,
the devas searched
for a healing elixir
at the bottom of a milky ocean.
But in their churning
brought up many treasures
from the depths.
It's unclear what type of
tree the Kalpavriksha is,
though many compare
it to the banyan,
one of India's
most sacred trees.
Myths like these
make trees sacred,
or at least worthy of
our care and protection.
Other stories act
as cautionary tales
that scare us into looking
after our woody friends.
Japanese folklore has
tales of the Jubokko,
a yokai who forms
when enough blood
has been violently
spilled on its roots.
These trees who have
seen too little kindness
and received too few thanks
turn hostile and use
their sharp branches
to grab anyone who gets too
close and drain their blood.
Having grown up surrounded
by trees in a lifestyle
slightly more reminiscent
of our ancestors than most,
I personally understand
the importance
of treating them well.
A sick tree on your
property can fall down
on your possessions
or spread rot to its neighbors.
Trees become the stuff of
nightmares when we neglect them,
but they literally keep us alive
when we give them
the bare minimum of care.
Let's all take a hint from
these ancient cultures
all over the world and
stop every once in a while
to see trees
for the true gifts they are.
Clearly having a close
connection with nature
is something very
personal to me,
which is why
I'm so excited to tell you
about a new series on PBS Terra
called "Women of the Earth."
It's a series that
introduces you to women
who are pioneering
movements to heal the Earth
from climate change.
There is a link in
the description.
We hope you check it out
and the rest of PBS's
Earth Month playlist too.
[no audio]
Accessibility provided by the
U.S. Department of Education.
[no audio continues]